all right
well I hello good evening good afternoon
wherever you are in the world if you're
in Britain you're sweating
immensely
blowing me
oh I haven't got a book I should have
got a fan in here but it would have
you'd have received it and the whole way
through the video
hi guys how you doing Matt Harris good
it's going down here on the Tuesday
what's going on
well I was going to comment on my own
and just chat to you lovely people in
the comments but I'll ask you guys if
you're free and you are so
um
I did
[Music]
dinner bread I won't I won't talk in
there at all
I'm sorry
how are you doing Brett builds you're
new and we love you uh Sue Hobson but
what's that
backstabber Al pastas good name Tiki
Batman's in with us is anybody else in
with us at the moment
Marco saying hello sir right so
um oh right it's been quite an
interesting day I'll put it that way
um Matt you dropped me that video
um from Brian J Smith where he actually
says
I I need to call you out on something
about it the video you posted you kept
calling him John
yes
and it used to be a labor leader
his name's Brian
did I really just keep doing that
you know what that was a video doing at
seven o'clock in the morning very very
quickly so yeah someone sent me that
video on Discord last night so I watched
it this morning and I was like this this
we need to like get something out about
this because this is gold this B says
yeah so I sent it to you and then I call
them John
knows what he's talking about though
John was a clever boy and I he was
always my favorite on the show John he's
he's there John Smith
the most common name in a planet sure no
nobody nobody has gone in the comments
and and pointed that out I know in the
comments I was hoping someone would say
it but no wonder dozens of comments now
um well comments help and um I I I'll
stand by that I make one deliberate
error every single video uh just to see
if you guys pick it out and you know
realize yeah
yeah anyway so John said that he was
asked about whether he would return I
said that on a joke that was a joke uh
Brian said and he was asked would he
return to Stargate he said oh gotcha he
was actually talking to SGU in
particular and whether they do a movie
and then he said I know they're doing a
Revival
um he says a Revival or something he
actually said they're doing lots of
different things
which is really what I wanted to talk
about because if we're going to get he
actually then said that quote if you
want it hit me
so he said uh listen we're all
cryogenically frozen out there on
Destiny on that spaceship out there
somewhere in the cosmos so I mean if
it's it's kind of teed up for someone to
do a movie or something where we could
finish off that story and then it goes
on and says I know that they're doing
another Stargate that they're kind of
Reviving the franchise a little bit and
they want to do these big huge movies
he said a lot of ums and R's in between
that but I cut those out because
professional well I I think it was an
answer because he was a little bit I
think he might have felt a little bit on
the spot and he was just I almost wonder
whether halfway through he realized he
said too much I think well I don't know
we talk about this a little bit at the
beginning before the pre-show
um I think all of this is a little bit
too too
um coincidental to be accidental if that
makes sense yeah there are so many
interviews going up David blue did an
interview we'll talk about that a little
bit in in in in yeah yeah
um that now he's done it Robert Carlisle
obviously was in the same interview
uh he mentioned a load of stuff I didn't
actually quote anything on Robert color
on the nine chevron's post I probably
should
um
but they they they're all basically it
was David blue and Brian who basically
said that they know something is
happening
yeah which is why I made the article
um I I I I I honestly just think it's a
little bit too coincidental that they
both happen to go on podcasts or these
shows and say
these things whether it's a slip of the
tongue or not or a Freudian slip or
whatever you want to call it it's just
it's a little bit too like you know what
you're doing you're prepping us because
you're going to announce it in a month
yeah I I that's it I don't know if it's
Paris you might have an opinion on this
but I don't know if it's like on purpose
like basically MGM saying to them if you
get asked or actually and then you know
when they do these interviews they might
even be told you can ask about Stargate
would you ask about Stargate please
because that happens all the time that's
more along than what I think it was yeah
or is it just that
industry-wide this is this is the worst
kept secret
out there at the moment and just I mean
I'm getting I'm getting to the point now
that the the I talked to 11 or 12 people
that working around the audit I think
and they're basically saying yeah it's a
movie
this is looking towards it now it's
happening that's it I don't know whether
that's because
Amazon for the deadline they told
deadline two months ago we're thinking
about doing a movie
yeah which thing cash well that that
primes reporters to talk about it so if
it's not that if it's not like the
studio saying hey if you're talking to
these kind of people maybe you should
mention this they're probably referring
to the deadline article I guess we
haven't heard them like specifically
referred to it so that might be like
well maybe they are just getting like
talking points from an agent a producer
an executive somewhere along the lines
because they are talking about their own
shows that they're going on I uh uh
Robert Carlisle is full monty or
something like that and I don't remember
what Brian Smith was doing but
um the class of 96 or something
okay looks like yeah
yeah oh oh oh oh yeah uh that's the one
with him and Kate Mara and somebody else
uh-huh uh but but yeah I would think
that obviously they're going on these
things to talk about
those shows they want to be talking
about those shows that's what's airing
and that's what is getting them paid and
then getting them fed right now so
that's what they want to be talking
about but
if the bigger thing that will feed them
longer will come uh come across I guess
in the interview they're gonna be happy
to talk about it I'm sure that's like if
anybody it's their agent saying hey
maybe mention SGU a little bit yeah it
might be as simple as that and and yeah
just just primes all of us a little bit
more I I guess each bit it might not be
something yeah
this is gonna happen and you know what
we want to position you to maybe get a
role because I'm telling you what I was
told months ago David blue has not been
approached by this I've been told a few
names that have a few that I can't share
but Amanda tap in Michael Shanks and
Robert Carlisle apparently been
unofficially approached and David blue
said actually specifically they don't
want to approach him
apparently on social media and stuff is
a bit I don't follow him on Facebook but
I follow him on Twitter but apparently
he says some things occasionally which
were a bit um
I don't I don't know what that means
because I've not looked into it but
um
I don't know I do following but I'm not
seeing anything that's problematic but
now in the case of Brian I mean even in
the case of David as well yeah his
name's John yeah okay in the case of
John Ryan John
who knows uh in the case of either of
those actors uh they both mentioned in
both of their respective interviews that
SGU was their first regular role
so I guess I guess talking of it's Jacob
did you say
I guess for them talking about SGU uh is
is kind of like well this this is what
kick-started my career I want to go I I
would love to go back to the thing that
literally kicks out of my career because
they David blue
was an actor before but it was only a
reoccurring character and I think I'd be
better I think it was
and then he only became a series regular
his first proper gig when it when you
can see it have you have you watched the
entire interview by the way for David
blue that was a really good interview
oh yeah long but yeah I watched it it
was 100
yeah stuff about like talking about Brad
Wright stuff that used to go on behind
the scenes and things I I find that
fascinating it's stuff I've heard before
that you know this thing about how he
watches the actors and
um
yeah
sorry interesting the confessions made
the points because why were the actors
at fed concert very similar I would
argue actually they did
um I don't think they mentioned movies
but all of them talked about
that they think this is coming back
um I think Amanda Tapping was very cagey
on purpose because I think she knows a
lot more than she wanted to say and this
is the moment they are being told not to
not say anything but also I mean their
agents are approached a lot of the time
they don't the actor doesn't always know
the internets and the details of what's
going on the agent is the one that talks
to them and then tells them when there's
something concrete so yeah that's also a
possibility
I mean there are agents that might be
playing around like the actors might not
know all that much and they might be the
ones like priming them in the interviews
as well they might be priming the actors
just as much as they might be priming us
just mentally I guess yeah uh which is
kind of an agent's job in a lot of ways
is this get you prepared for your role
and get you the good ones
yeah oh another big announcement today
by the way Amazon they've literally
today announced that they're going to be
um dropping well they're gonna on
Freeview they're going to have a bunch
of dedicated Stargate channels six I
think it was six dedicated Stargate
channels and the last time they
announced this it was done within a
couple of days the channels just
appeared within a few days it doesn't
say when it doesn't say which districts
but this is in Germany Britain France
and America I believe for Evie and maybe
one or two other countries but I'm
hoping everybody gets it I think
freebies pretty much standard I think
across the yeah
fast free ad supporters streaming
television channels 12 the channels will
be drawn from MGM uh based around
Stargate and the outer limits I've never
seen that it's only good yeah the
outer limit is also rumored to be coming
back but that comes back every couple
years it gets canceled and comes back
every few years
Futurama Style
if anything Stargate is Futurama Star
right now which which is kind of makes
me happy because it's about the same
time didn't it like stop airing like a
decade ago
yeah uh uh-huh
well this year was like
2011. and I think Futurama stopped the
first time and or or maybe it had
stopped once before then but I remember
at least this either the first or the
second time it like stop stopped was
2013. so it's like right next to America
because it started what 97.99 kind of
range something like that yeah it was
like the perfect kind of decade of
sci-fi well we would just talk about
that okay we might think David blue said
this I have watched the full thing but
this I think that's what David police
said isn't it and why the fandom gets so
mad and then he talked about
um that sometimes we eat ourselves from
the inside out which I thought was quite
a descriptive way of saying it
SGU there's definitely a kick back from
SGU it got canceled because of MGM
getting
um Coming bankrupt basically and then
sci-fi not wanting to foot the bill
expensive show but also there was a
little bit of
it was a bit more complicated than David
blue talks about because there was also
the thing about for the third season
they had to re do everyone's contracts
the price was going to go up there was
the Canadian dollar was very strong
against the American dollars that was
forcing the price to show basically it's
just a perfect storm of everything went
wrong all at once
um
but there was definitely a kickback
interesting what he said about
um when Atlantis got announced uh as
being canceled and then they put SGU in
the same article he basically
alluded to the fact that that that gave
fans the ammunition to say we hate SGU
because it canceled it Atlantis when
that was
from his point of view that was never
the case Atlantis was always it was
getting canceled anyway and they were
just at the same time just trying to
announce a new show yeah I can kind of
see it I can kind of see that because
I'm pretty sure
I read that article
back in like 2009
and I was like so they're canceling
Atlantis for this new show but that's
what I thought reading it so it did come
across like that
yeah
Sue is going to ask Amanda for us so
that'd be great
um if you can get a video of her saying
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel as well and send it to us
as our intro
I'll send you one and get the photo with
Amanda Tapping that do me
so see you get in touch no problem at
all on it
um you can have a size that's sg1 that
goes for anyone who meets anyone
um he did actually say though
um John Brian and that
um I can't believe he did that but
anyway let's talk about movies now I've
always said that back
when Amazon first started talking about
this they wanted to do a
um they were using like Marvel and Star
Wars as like a blueprint that always
gets people angry they're like I don't
want anything like Star Wars nothing
Disney but I don't mean it like that I
mean it they're using it as a as a
blueprint of movies and TV series and
maybe games that all influence each
other they're all
um you know that one affects the other
sort of thing which is something we've
not really seen a lot of before Marvel
started doing it and then Star Wars dude
um so
movies
would work on that but I've never heard
anybody say to me more than movie
followed very quickly by TV series
that's all I've heard up till now what
do we think about this and it is the
title of the video movies movies
they're expecting them to be like I'll
be happy
if they're big
they're spectacular and they do well
great more stargate's gonna come so
that's like I've nothing else to say
maybe they're finding a trilogy
that seems like the most plausible
honestly as long as it's not the
original trilogy from Roland Eric Dean
Devlin as long as I don't go down that
route I'm happy
would I be crazy if I wanted that to be
made but like not part of Stargate at
the same time just be its own little
like
no I have said this before I I did want
to see I did want to see how it played
out but I still love fun candy if you
bring if you if they make it and then it
flops which it will because it's going
to be crap
um
um Bob's so the Stanley's pointer
um the guy Malcolm reads the Dominic I
think is his name he acts he's very very
strange
is that the British dude yeah he comes
across quite eccentric
on the uh on the shuttle pod
um podcast
I'd never seen the guy before I thought
it was rush for a second I was like yeah
um it's he's a very strange fella let me
put that way
yeah
um
but a lot of actors are
uh what are we saying sorry that just I
just saw that point and just thought it
was interesting
um moving movie movies movies movies
um
would we be happy with the trilogy if it
means we didn't get a TV series
no I'd rather than do a movie I didn't
like the caveat at the end there yeah I
I want I want a series because a series
you can dive
way more into you can get way bigger
story and it can have an arc that goes
multiple seasons and it's it's just what
we're used to and what we enjoyed about
Stargate to begin with
I want a movie yeah kind of because it
would be big and it's a bit spectacular
and it'd be exciting
but yeah I would take series over movie
any day if they didn't if they scrap the
entire movie plan and just give us a
series I'd be like happy as Larry
but
I've a movie might fit with certain
properties within Stargate better like
like I think Destiny if they're gonna go
find destiny that needs to be a movie
that does not need to be a TV they don't
need to take a season of Television to
do that they don't need to take half a
season of Television a third of season
of a television show to do that that
might be better to do in maybe not the
first movie but like in a second movie
and then have the third movie like
interact with Earth again and that's how
you get back and and then you can have a
couple different like starting points
um
I I feel like yeah honestly a movie
feels more acclimated to SGU I feel like
sg1's had a couple good TV movies and
those are always fun and that would work
it would work for SGA as well but
I I was thinking about this SGU movie
idea right and I've always said they're
not going to do an sdg movie it wasn't
popular enough but whenever we do videos
in SGU they always do really really well
always I think I have two of our top
three videos we've ever done are SGU
yeah move videos
um and the only one is maybe Firefly I
think is the other one so I mean they
always do I think the reason is like
Firefly Firefly is a cult following way
after the fact of it being be an aired
Target Universe kind of had that as well
it wasn't very popular when it was on I
mean it was it was probably there were
millions of people that enjoyed it I was
one of them but there was obviously the
the people that didn't like it but since
then I think this is something that
David blue said in the in his interview
actually as well but there's Millions
more people have enjoyed it since it's
not been on the air
and I think that's why videos that we do
particularly on slogan Universe do so
well because the people who are just
discovering Stargate Universe want to
know what's what's what happened to the
destiny is there a season three
oh
and having issues kick me out real quick
come back in a minute
and SGU it would have done way better
see I don't think it was ahead of its
time I think it was like literally
perfectly timed and then did The Perfect
Storm to take it out and just happen it
just happened to happen at that time
because literally what it ended in 2011
2012 it ran I think yeah 10 and 11 were
like the seasons that aired or years it
aired what else came out in 2011 that
changed the landscape of TV Game of
Thrones after that was the the expanse
and a lot of other things like that it's
it's
it
it changed I I don't know if Stargate
Universe is the thing that changed the
landscape of TV honestly but uh I'm back
can you hear me
yeah
cool uh
but welcome to my job
it's beautiful
well one day we're praying uh so Harris
come on
oh I'm add hold up I'll get right back
to it um
oh Game of Thrones stuff so so like like
literally where Stargate was like
Universe said we have to change the
campy fun aspect of it which we also do
love the campy fun aspect of things the
landscape of TV was changing like
literally at that time and I don't know
if SGU was like the thing that did that
but it brought that era I guess into
grounded more more realistic television
that that gritty darker television
because literally everything before that
everything that was popular that I mean
obviously we're in nerdy circles and you
know if at that time it was like
Smallville or or something like that but
everything where it had some grit to it
it was all quote unquote campy still and
every TV show afterwards has been very
different in everything the CW has ever
done other than Arrow has always been we
are happy family friends and we can save
the world we just believe in ourselves
Supernatural was like bad Supernatural
was pretty dark
is the fact that SGU is kind of a
controversial though another reason or
another strength for why actually it
might make sense to bring that back
Thrift movie
okay
it would cause
people to keep
yeah it would definitely 100
I mean I can see the headlines now the
show that killed Stargate is back
people would literally write that
article but it would get people watching
it it wouldn't then go this didn't kill
stagger this is amazing oh and then
they'd all like like punch themselves in
the face because they know they were
wrong
Aaron well we'll ask thank you very much
for turning up mate but there's a lot of
noise oh I'm sorry
where do you work by the way just out of
Interest I work at a tire wholesaler in
the warehouse
and latch of tires
so we know where to go when we need our
winter tires yeah
um but I will not be covering the
overseas shipping
okay
I had a flat tire two days ago
um
if you don't mind mate but I'll thank
you so much for especially while you're
still at work but it's really long here
I'll pick that one second
that's a solution I like it right so I
I'm wondering whether yeah the
controversy might be a bonus I I think
that it's
um
it just adds to the thing and definitely
in a social media age it just adds a bit
more to it but I just need to comment on
that uh it doesn't smell funny but when
he goes home he's always tired
I was
I'll do that I like it yeah very good
very good
um but also I would argue that the SGU
storyline maybe is a bit more like
what we're used to on TV except I would
say I think there's a big Nostalgia
thing going on at the moment first of
all is Nostalgia for the 80s now it's
just Nostalgia for like all teenage it's
always been quite popular you know the
18 moving every other thing but it
really seems like it's nostalgic sci-fi
is a big deal at the moment and you know
might rape ride that wave of Picard they
did it with Quantum Leap they're doing
it with Star Trek they're doing it with
well Outer Limits apparently which I
didn't know but yeah it comes back all
constantly every every couple years if
they do it better than lucasfilm I'll be
happy
the aliens have actually been properly
announced I saw that yesterday the the
Alien series from Noah Holly
um yeah I'm just yeah itching for that
one
I just saw something about a uh was it
Peregrine or Uruguayan director is about
to get his alien movie man that's
supposed to come out right next week oh
uh parrot Paraguay is I know you're
talking about I think
um
I can't remember who he is at the time I
had I can Google it real quick I know
what you're talking about I mean yeah
that is supposed to be
pretty much green lit Now isn't it I
think it's been that it was Green at
least at one point wasn't it but then
they lose the director
whose name I'm gonna forget
and that's where they got the new guy I
think yeah they got this new guy and and
a co-writer I think they're both
paraglong I believe it's definitely
green lit now because there was an
official like
poster
from the studio
which is always good when we get a
poster yeah that basically is the green
that's the rubber St seal nowadays
could forget a poster
virtually enough it's like fading
something something uh is it fetty
Alvarez is that it yes okay yes yes he's
done a couple other like things that are
actually really good uh uh
he did he did he did a horror movie or
two that I can't think of off the top of
my head but he he is good
don't hit it don't breathe that's right
yeah yeah when I looked him up they said
horror movie director that was like
that's like his his his thing
and he did the 2013 Evil Dead remake
that's that's he's got a good place in
my life oh okay bam I like that because
I let a lot of people didn't like that
movie I like that movie
I still need to see the new one that's
in theaters right now I feel bad that I
haven't seen that one but that and then
people that arise yeah the preview all
the trailers look dope for that Harry
she watched like 50 films a day you
shouldn't feel bad
there's supposed to be an IMDb up in
here
when neuralink is a thing the first
thing I'm doing is just downloading the
entire IMDb database just right in the
back just download all the movies
in your heads
anyway
um so yeah like I said we were told to
go back to Stargate we were told over a
year ago just before this was announced
we'd get Amazon talking about it we'd
get a load of news reports talk about
we'd get the actors talking about it so
I put a poll on the channel a little
early saying basically do we think guys
this is
basically Stargate open
um or is the Stargate still closed and
at the moment after 498 votes seven only
70 percent are actually confident that
this is basically it that we're we're
just on the precipice of the
announcement 30 people is good most
people think most people think I'll
believe it when I see it kind of thing
yeah and to be fair we've been
disappointed so many times
yeah someone in in these comments here I
saw it I I don't know who said it
um it's all one month until we could be
disappointed again I get I get the
mindset because yeah we might and
hopefully we don't but that is
unfortunately the state we are in look
we have rumors at the end of the day
Brad Wright script got destroyed by
covid just did and then this sale and
Amazon weren't so Keen to go with Brad
Wright's plan
um and then we thought maybe it would
get announced around the anniversary
last year
um but really that was just based on a
couple of people going it would make
sense if we know that we know they want
to do it and actually even in marketing
meetings that was because I I just one
person I speak to gets gets her ear in a
lot of hinoshi could be Hiroshi
um
they they get there a lot of marketing
means and the marketing team will go in
let's just announce something it doesn't
have to be that you know we're just
we'll just announce that you know we're
thinking about it and the the executive
was like no you can't say anything
um so and then we thought maybe in
January but again that was just based
really on we thought it made sense
to announce it and a couple of people in
Iran will go in it would make sense
but they didn't what I'm looking forward
to is it did make sense
honestly or whatever they called what
they call is it called a shuttlepod
should a podcast or whatever it is
called isn't it yeah
yeah other one Danny uh the one the uh
the Eli was on yeah yeah they've got um
I don't know if it's next week or week
after
they've got
um Brad Wright coming on and I'm looking
forward to that because that might be
telling
yeah it is 23 000 subscribers we have
20. that'll be dope we get
um between 100 and 200 000 views a week
the channel is doing very nicely guys
but yes like subscribe hit the Bell
notification do all that business share
the video where you can if you know a
Gator fan that isn't following our
Channel let them know
we want to get to 50K so I can get
tattooed live on air
um I might not do it live
um
well you have to do it live that'll be
the most fun
yeah but you've seen the grown man cry
you won't cry multiple times mostly
myself but multiple times it seems like
crazy I've got a tattoo that got quite
close to my nipple and that was the only
time I've actually gone I don't like it
because it felt like it was it felt like
it was cutting my nipple off it was good
but
um
so it's a Sidetrack uh tram stamp right
yeah I'm gonna [__] stamp side truck
here there we go the logo
um I'm probably gonna get on my arm but
or I might get in a buttock who knows
what you should do is in between just so
you've got to say this is this is the
these are the cheeks you need it a
sargate here so
[Laughter]
and then make sure you eat something
spicy so you get the full effect of when
the gate
you can tell every time you have a
burrito or blokes in this bloody thing
we really need girls in the series
we're not engaged
so
um Andrew Chandler's had an interesting
storyline so would it be 18 months from
announcements to broadcast if they get a
cinematic movie announcement to cinema
would be at least 18 months
they could 12 months is possible but it
would be more likely to be 18 months
because yes the only caveat there would
be like if the script is ready and like
all they got to do is just make sure
actors contracts worked out get them all
timed up right and then just go at it
yeah
um and I I would actually say probably
18 months from when filming starts is
more likely
so I mean that could even be two years
from announcement to be fair yeah at
least six months to do these things so
um
if it's a series
nowadays 12 months
it used to be
two or three months you know they would
be filming and the show would air within
about a month of filming but that
doesn't happen anymore yeah I know that
pain with the flash season 9 film last
year I saw all the set leaks and I'm
like just want to see it it's the finale
I need to see it I don't have to wait a
whole year
yeah it's because of the CGI and stuff
nowadays just with that with that
mindset
would y'all rather whenever a show does
come back whether it be after the movies
while movies are going on but prior to a
movie if we're lucky whatever it may be
would Joe rather it be that like
of course selfishly like I love star
dating it year in year out but it could
take the Game of Thrones it could take
the stranger things route where it's
streaming every other year and they
could give us something really really
really really sweet as as so my opinion
on that would be as long as
they can deliver something good if they
can do it every every year
fine but if they're going to need to
take an extra an extra year to make sure
it's good to make sure that maybe the
budget needs to stretch like another
year just to get to make it as good as
it can be kind of like what stranger
things is doing we have to wait I think
it's now like two two three years
that's not because of filming and that's
because the actors are stupidly busy
they weren't going to do another season
with it at one point and then they
decided they're gonna do another season
they re-shot everything and and so they
you know they there was a lot of reasons
why it's going to be so long
um and the bigger problem with stranger
things is they got really popular in
lockdown when nobody was working so
they'd already and all the kids were
still aging and they were all season
what the season one and two is on the
audio on Netflix and then I think just
after lockdown I did season three might
be wrong on that I'm pretty sure that's
right yeah basically and but then they
also do movies it'll start doing other
things they it's doing their Bobby Brown
is doing absolutely everything at the
moment
he's not doing as much but he he did a
few ones and then he now he's directing
so
[Music]
20 year old out here directing to teach
me I need to learn how to do that this
[__] 2000 makes a really good point now
that that's I I was told that's what
they're going to do that it'll be movies
and series that like say influence each
other and that one Builds on the other
and it'll be like chapters in a book
which is why I always explained but very
Star Wars in the way Star Wars are
trying to do at the moment even though
they keep effing it up but um if they're
smart they'll do what Marvel's been
doing lately which is they'll be filming
the movie and then once they're done
with that set they'll if it's a common
set they'll use that they'll start
shooting scenes for the TV show or what
have you Marvel's been doing that in the
last few months
the guy I was talking to he doesn't know
this is what they were doing but he said
basically it sounded like that's what
basically they were going to try to do
was that they will have one set or one
Sound Stage so they can basically film
both on and the actors would be crossing
over like crazy as well and but then
it's a way of keeping the costs down
because the cost is going to be
important
and this is one of the the points they
would he was trying to make if you say
look the the I know these budgets don't
sound massive and he was talking about
90 million for the movie and then maybe
six million per episode for the series
this is but a lot of those costs come
initially a lot of those costs come from
getting the actors on board
getting all the contracts sorted and
building sets if you can sort of shift
costs between the two and they do this
because they they they fiddle I'm not
going to say they fiddle the taxes
because that would be liables
they're very careful to minimize taxes
um and that's one of the things they do
they like sort of like they move money
around so there's like
um
fancy business accounting yeah cost on
the movie and get the budget down on the
series because that's going to cost us a
bit more and then what they'll do is
they'll get those you know those French
Dudes who've made the the really big
Stargate
yeah yeah they'll buy that off of them
claim it as an art piece don't have to
pay tax on that yeah
and then you and then use it
if there's more
that's a bad idea yeah
but they can make it functional oh
actually no it's already functional it's
enormous isn't it well not in that it
can generate a wormhole to other stars
but yeah it spins
and lights up and everything
um but yeah the general I say it should
spin only a few guys just straight up if
you had to scale it like we'll do we'll
do the Chevrons thing and we'll only do
one to seven Matthew I know you like
doing one to nine but one to seven
chevrons
how confident are you that we're going
to get an announcement either at San
Diego Comic Con or within the next
couple of months I actually think it'll
match depend on when the right to strike
I think it'll be after the rotor strike
personally I'm gonna say six because
then
you've always got that because it's it's
it's it's literally
it will or it won't so everyone will
engage or it won't engage like
we we all hope we've got the right
address and it's going to engage yeah
yeah
I'd I'd go five out of seven
for for that same I'd go dial it back to
six just kind of that teetering there
but I I'd push it back to five because
honestly like we were just saying a
minute ago
I bet you they were gonna announce stuff
way early this year and the reason they
didn't wasn't because oh we want to do
it a San Diego Comic-Con it was they
they knew the writer strike was coming
and and they knew about it and were
thinking about it way before we ever
were you know uh we we do get things we
I mean we get nice rumors quickly and
all that kind of stuff but it doesn't
compete with the actuality of like the
industry it's it's always moving whether
we're talking about it on a stream or
not you know so I I I'm thinking I would
at least assuming makes an ass out of
you and me but I'm assuming nonetheless
that uh they were ready to announce and
they've probably been ready to announce
and they're just really waiting and and
that kind of pertains to uh
what what they'll do I guess because it
would be nice for them to be able to cut
cost and and put like a show after a
movie or a TV special after uh they film
a movie like like Aaron was talking
about with Marvel how they do like now
they're doing like Thunderbolts and and
a little TV thing or they did guardians
galaxy and a little TV special and
they're doing a couple things just for
saving a couple bucks
um
if they do that uh I I I it'd be nice if
they did that and I guess prepared like
almost three years ahead but I just
don't see that happening right now with
all the writing uh going on or writer
strike going on um just to say that um
Sunday uh Sunday Kind of in the stories
for keeping stuff secret and having big
surprises that no one's expecting
um but he's right and um but I do know
that um MGM or Amazon have do have got a
couple of conference rooms that they
booked out
but a couple of other people have booked
things like um I know Disney had several
booked out and one of those people you
know a very close friend of the the
channels don't we they canceled them
they booked two or three and after the
right strike thing they just went they
did they pulled out they decided they're
not gonna do it and Warner Brothers
again they have four or five things
planned and they've decided not to at
San Diego Comic-Con so sending a
Comic-Con might be a red herring
um but I think that was mentioned in the
deadline article is that I think that's
where we're getting that from and I I've
it's been mentioned to me a couple of
times but only from opinion that people
think if they're going to announce it in
July
that's when they were denounce it
um so but I just think it look at like a
bloody news reporter do me but what do
you think one to seven how many Chevrons
are locked down
are we talking just an announcement
period or an announcement at San Diego
because an announcement period I'm at
five period yeah I'm at five chevron's
on that one just because
Hollywood is Hollywood and I don't trust
them completely but I'm mostly I'm
mostly confident we're gonna get our
announcement this year for sure
yeah I would be amazed if we didn't get
an answer this summer I'd be shocked but
I think I'm at five as well
but not I would have been at six if all
this was happening the writer strike
wasn't going on I think the right to
strike creates
an element of doubt and Executives from
what I've seen are a jittery Bunch
wasn't there a deal struck last week
though
didn't happen I've got the director's
got a deal yeah I've got a video coming
out at eight o'clock that deal with the
DJ might not be as secure as we think
um so
I don't want to ruin that video though
so you have to go watch that video at
eight o'clock but um yeah it might be
about to get much much worse for the
studios
Rank and file not down with the deal huh
yeah so it's all going to pot
um well I'm still going to keep my
answer at six because I honestly think
thank you
as I said at the beginning of the show I
just think this is all too coincidental
to be accidental
like all these people saying all their
stuff like it it has to be there has to
be a reason but they've all just decided
to go on podcast all of a sudden David
blue has his own podcast so I can kind
of forgive him for going on the podcast
because he has out of the blue where he
he gets sci-fi I guess all the time but
then you've got
Robert Carla and then you've got John
AKA Brian and then you're gonna you're
gonna have Brad right next week and then
I think there was another one I can't
remember who it might have been David
Hewlett but I don't think it was
um
he's going on as well yeah like I know
he's like probably more so Star Trek but
I just thinking yeah
they already mentioned they mentioned
him yesterday and they're talking with
David blue they talked about Robert
Carter a couple of times they mentioned
him
Aaron's chin is awesome look at Lounge
chin
[Music]
honestly Ricardo someone or I said
Ricardo that's that's my new nickname
for him uh but he was someone I did not
expect to enjoy on uh Atlantis and then
he ended up being like one of my
favorite characters in that season I was
like I I was I was pissed off and I was
like really you're taking Sam out for
for for Woolsey
they wanted us to hate him but then they
made us fall in love with him how dare
they
episode two like the first half of the
episode he was in I was like I'm kind of
starting to like him
what was it like a cold a cold like
clinical man yeah I would say and then
then he [__] he showed emotion
they're like what the hell is this
he was always one of my favorite he was
always my favorite in Voyager
um I remember he um he posted a picture
with it where he had hair that I
actually posted Jesus Christ when did
you have hair and he he replied you know
I know right
um
but uh but yeah I was like Ricardo was
great on Voyager I've tried to get him
I've tried to get in contact with him
and I can't get in contact with him I'm
gonna see if I can get to this agent I'd
love I've been trying to get him and
David him and David Hewlett I would give
good money to get them on the channel
David blue followed us on Sidetrack on
Tick Tock for about five minutes he
actually did follow I wasn't I wasn't
making it up like he followed us I sent
him a little wave and he unfollowed us
that's what you did I really wanted his
like to start a conversation with him
like try and get him on the foot no
maybe that was the problem soundtrack
I actually joked that um Brian is
probably just a side tracker he's
probably watching us so Brian if you are
watching oh my God there's a guy there's
a there's a guy brain brain pain or
something who watches us brain Brian
brain pain are you here I have not seen
him dyslexia brain pain because he's uh
he's got a headache Brian it's an
anagram I know and it's a secret
um but Brian if you are watching or
anybody from Stargate ever or if anybody
knows anybody from Stargate who's ever
appeared on it I'd love to get like dual
state or something like that and I'd
just like to adore it
um
I will give money to charity to get them
on the channel whatever charity they
want even though I did get in touch with
who I thought there's a Facebook
official page for John Shepard and he
was trying to give he was trying he said
oh you've got to give me money for
charity and he was like being beaten me
up beating me up like five six hundred
pounds and I was like uh getting a bit
much and then he said but you've got to
send it to me directly not send it to
the charity and I'm like but I've got
the link for the charity I've got the
information here did he want to send you
it via Bitcoin yes you want to be sent
it by by a Bitcoin yet and I'm just like
piss off
that is not real that's not that's not
joking yeah wouldn't that be Joe Flynn
again no it was not him but um
you because you messaged me yeah and I
started telling my misses I'm like we're
gonna potentially get Joe Flanagan
Africa and it's gonna be amazing and
then you get and then and then it turns
out to be a bloody scam is affecting
kind of artists
um I spoke to again somebody that does
know him a little bit and he says he
only ever talks to people he doesn't
talk to people like that he'll go
through his age and anything like that
goes through his age but um again
anybody that knows something like police
would would have anybody on here anybody
I want to talk to the guy who played
um his name's Gary something
Gary he played Walter
what's his name yeah
Sidetrack says seven Chevrons locked or
something like that and that I'd be I'd
be happy
um you know they do those greeting card
things and you can pay for Cameo what to
say if you do that just get into it and
just like yeah unless you spend 300
pounds to get someone to say sidetrack
um
but but yeah um I would kill to get
David he replied to me once on Facebook
actually I should try and get him on
again
um uh he he reposed he sent it if he
could have posted a picture of him when
he was a kid like 18 19 years old and I
said damn Dave you were a good looking
guy he and he was just like what do you
mean whilst
I've seen pictures of him before he was
in when he was younger and I'm like
is that sexy Squidward like
sex is good for when he's younger
Squidward now but
um yeah I said some silly commenting he
liked it and took the piss back but he's
such a funny guy I've killed everyone
again
he's always on nerdgasm
yeah
it's like Brad Ryan follows this on
Twitter
and so I've sort of like try to sort of
like befriend him
but he would never come on he's
obviously he's linked to companion and
stuff so and and to be honest I feel bad
when I ask him things anyway but I do
ask his opinion on Suffocation and he
always answers
um if you don't ask you don't get I
reckon we at some point just ask him
is it at all possible in the future
if ever you want to come on I would give
money to charity whatever where you want
and and
then I give at the moment I give 10 of
our earnings on side track every month
to charity last month it was mine the
next month it's going to be a dwarfism
charity because my um my niece basically
office so
um and but every month we give something
so I would more than happily
give the entire bad right game when I
give the entire Monsoon into whatever we
earn that month
um to charity so I'll maybe I'll be the
best month ever because of that
interview yeah yeah it's an interview
and the tax write-offs would be great
that month yeah
um but yeah anybody you seem to report a
really expensive RPS
number two
I'm gonna buy myself a massive um
Stargate model it costs like 600 Quid
off this guy Off from Twitter and then I
think I wonder if I can scratch that off
if I put it in the background and say
it's a work thing something this big 3D
printed deadlas it's like five I was
just about to say so for San Diego
Comic-Con next year y'all know I have a
3D printer in my shed right here we can
walk in there with the full ass whatever
we want
can you 3D print a gold emblem that I
can stick on my head yes ignore it with
gold permanent marker oh that's crap I
want the actual thing
and can you can you 3D print me as that
nicotyle and can you also 3D print me a
fully a full-size Asgard and a deadlift
that works
if you send me the right uh whatever
it's called the right code for it
because I don't actually understand how
to use it I have smartphones
. yeah there you go perfect
yeah no okay we're 3D printing our dress
up game
um we are hoping to go to Comic-Con next
year and
um yeah we might we might have to
crowdfund me or something so my wife let
me go but um it'd be amazing I think
maybe it'd be amazing just to come over
and meet you stormy meet Aaron maybe you
know like say I think you're a different
boss of America but you install me are
pretty close in your house so
um
trust me as soon as I can get out to
Nevada I got my best friend lives there
I would love to get out Southwest
come on
next next year I'd have gone this year
if I thought about it but sooner because
I could say if if if they announced it
San Diego Comic-Con and I think with the
writer strike it's a massive I think it
would I think they would have done
something if
um because that's the thing is that they
love to announce these things in San
Diego Comic-Con that's why it's the
biggest they love announcing stuff there
and they love doing surprise things
there like I said I think it's clipped
and shared so many times yeah oh yeah
but it's probably the most famous
Comic-Con on the planet so I mean the
studios love going there and they love
you know they think
um but
I just think
ing if I didn't if I wasn't there but
next year I think it'll be just before
the movie comes out so I think there'll
be a big Stargate presence
if if things go like we're expecting so
I'll just have to take that as a nice
second oh so who are your cards playing
as
sorry who are we cars playing as uh I'll
beat bill because I've got the least
hair you're not going to go as goal as
um as steel can are you sure
hmm because if I try to beat yolk I
would be
um canceled
yes that's true
yeah I could be General Hammond I'll
shave my beard I could be General
Hammond yeah cool
that would be the Tom treyar guy
because because when I say
I don't want to be here when I shave my
beard I do have quite a baby face like
like George does so yeah
Sue wants to come with a suit you come
on Carrie you're gonna come down San
Diego Comic-Con
Shelly everybody get get over um if we
come over Kerry we will maybe have a
stopover in Canada and say hello because
I'd love to meet silly as well
um and I'll bring Steve from stranger
things because Shelley wants to jump him
so um
my mate my mate uh my mate Steve Fisher
says you have to do a Texas accent for
him and Matt I'll train you don't worry
the hottest day of the year
you just go get a Jedi picking outfit
and just and depending on which geek you
come across I'm oh yeah I'm a Jedi or
well man yeah yeah I know I don't know
um this is Shelly yes Steve
she's she's gonna break it in the best
way
um but yeah well after I have a chat
about that when we when we come up to it
but yeah we'd love to absolutely adore
to do that
um right guys I I think it's been a
really really interesting day from
Stargate point of view I think we're
getting closer and closer and the thing
I'm getting excited about is that
because what I was told was would happen
is happening and I think that's that's
why I'm so excited and wanted to go live
so I can talk about it again and um
and I can't wait for Stargate to be on
Freezy
I know I'm quite excited about that I
can watch Stargate at work
uh well yeah I haven't watched Atlantis
in years
um so I'm really looking forward to
watching I've got Stargate sg1 on DVD
and it's the only reason I've still got
a DVD player
[Music]
um
because I moved them over to hard drive
so I got them on the Plex server so I
can watch them all at home
but I can't watch them outside of my
home and obviously Amazon doesn't have
them without paying for them again which
I'm not going to do
so
yeah but um
yeah I've been doing a few little videos
talking about Atlantis and stuff so I've
been reading up and I'm remembering all
these videos these episodes that I've
forgotten oh my god I've forgot that
episode there's a clip that keeps
popping up on my Tick Tock from I think
the names like Stargate fan on on there
um of Rodney like losing his memory and
I cannot remember this episode at all so
I need I need to find that is that
ironic that you've forgotten the episode
where Rodney forgot his memory it might
be a little bit ironic
irony isn't it
um now I know who you have to cosplay as
oh man goes Rodney
Rod I could not be Rodney I can guys
Rodney we've got enough to let my hair
grow a bit but I could go as Rodney I'm
gonna I'm gonna go samka
and nobody can say anything I could be
Woolsey again
yeah
keep the beard and everything you'll be
good
yeah I'm obviously on a bad day
has anybody got any ideas what they what
sort of movie they'd like to see before
we go
what sort of movie do we actually want
to see I want to see him I I do want to
see him do a Stargate Universe like
rescue well not not even a rescue just a
conclusion I just want to know what
happens do they definitely die or what
like I just want to know what happens
they don't necessarily have to go back
to Earth I just wanna I just want
something to happen
like like
sg1 or SGA movie would be really cool
and it would be really fun
but they they got their conclusions sg1
got a little more than just their
conclusion you know and and not
necessarily we weren't necessarily happy
like that it's all said and done but
the only thing that didn't get like a
finality like those Final Shots for SGU
are sad because you're just like wait
am I gonna wait three years for like the
next season like wait or or or what's
going on no you gotta wait forever we're
just 12 years later yeah legit it took
the 10 10 years
12 years later cool SpongeBob
and he comes in with a robotic eye and a
robotic arm so that was fun in Toy Story
2 where woody sees Woody's Roundup and
he's watching the show and he's like oh
this is a great show let's watch the
final episode and they go they can't the
network canceled it but it was a great
show it's exactly that
yeah
I think so I'd love to say I like the
idea of an SGU movie
shut up Siri
they could they could like have
something to do with Atlantis as well
because that didn't really get a
conclusion like The Wraith
well look Andrew's straight to Paso will
it be a softer reboot I was always told
but this was before the decisions were
made when Jennifer salkin got involved
and started saying movie and when
everyone MGM was saying TV series and
then just thought he went movie and then
went TV series
and Jennifer Sulkin went oh by the way I
paid the checks and I'm your boss movie
and they went there and looking at me
um but I was always told it was going to
be sort of like a hybrid reboot
bits would be
um
new
and bits would be
um revived so it's not going to be a
straight-up Revival like say
um Criminal Minds was recently you know
where it was canceled and it come back
or Dexter was a couple of years ago and
it's not going to be that
and it's not going to be a soft reboot
like Star Trek the Next Generation was
it'll be something in between they did
Dexter
property
because it killed him
yeah okay
I thought you meant a new texture
they just did him dirty like they left
it on season eight as is he like he
faked his death now he's living happily
in like
he's a lumberjack or whatever yeah it's
a lumberjack
oh
I liked New Blood I just didn't like the
fact that they killed him please why why
go through all the effort to have one
final season just to kill him
I never got it kill his son that's fine
his son wasn't [__] up
he was such a jerk I didn't like that I
didn't like the actor at all I never
said the word jerk but he was a jerk
um I think I think it's at fitting for
teenagers when they're idiots
yeah uh nine Chevrons in gateworld are
going to blow up Gable's already blown
up Cable's got a hundred thousand
subscribers him doing a video in years
[Applause]
hello
but yeah I hopefully hopefully SDC uh
all right then guys I I think that's
covers it we're all excited
um very excited
um I literally saw that video and made a
whooping noise and the wife thought I'd
hurt myself
I'm running back in you're right
um and I was like yeah this guy just
said it's definitely happening and we've
no I think we've known it's definitely
happening for a while
um but but I mean there's nothing else
when it comes from someone who's like
been invested in the show like fit in
the show because if they've got contacts
and stuff and you know they've got
contacts yeah it just means more because
it's like that extra bit of credibility
well the thing is I mean it's it's like
it's like anything in life isn't it like
you can be and unless you unless you're
an idiot
and and we always try to you know be
honest about the rumors that we've got
on the how there are some things I hear
that I'm pretty confident with and
there's some things in here I'm not so
confident with and I'll try to say when
I'm not so confident I think uh this
this is the rumor I'll tell you guys
because I've been told but I'm like uh
um
but at the end of the day until this is
like a football transfer until a guy
stood there with a shirt
stuff can go wrong
and until it's actually even when this
is greenlit and announced
don't be 100 confident because
the movie in 2015. yeah we've got burnt
before
yeah well we didn't we got saved before
but
yeah yeah I think so so look and all
stuff can always go wrong but
yeah
oh it's exciting
um I did two videos last week talking on
the same day talking about rumors and I
got a load of messages
and I'm like no because I love talking
about my favorite show we were talking
about it it's gonna come back
hopefully yeah exactly like David blue
said that the fandom need to be heard by
Amazon you know so this is all we're
trying to do but actually there's no
I talk about it because I love talking
about it this is my favorite show I in
the end of the day do videos about stuff
I want to talk about I don't do videos
trying to get Clips I don't do videos
trying to you know like get our numbers
up or whatever why we've all just
decided to spend an hour of our evenings
or mornings and those two cases mid
afternoon come on here and talk to 60 70
yard people because we want to talk
about the show we love
hell yeah
exactly
anything else yeah just just because
it's a show we love and and we get
excited talking about it and um I will
never do a video
for clicks I do a video because it's
something I want I don't bother
you know it's just nice at the moment
that there's lots going on so I've got a
lot to talk about
anyway guys it's really good thank you
so much for taking up some of your
mid-afternoon morning evening to talk
about
um the show we love
[Music]
um
we're crossing things Crossing toes
Crossing everything else that this
really is the um
um that this really is the the final
stages it feels like the final stages to
me
um
let's hope so let's hope so yeah as
you're encroaching on your Premiere
right now yeah well I think it's already
aired on here what are you going to do
what it says
guys thank you so much I'll see you all
later go and watch the other video go
watch the other video
go watch it and come say howdy
awesome okay okay oh yes oh Harris
you're gonna go live in a minute aren't
you I think yeah
eating the rest of this and then we're
literally talking about what the video
is premiering right now so watch that
I will do sir because you never invite
me I've noticed y'all are always invited
I also don't know
how do I invite people from YouTube is
my next question
um from the YouTube app
oh let's see I don't know how to do that
from YouTube I just do it through stream
yards yeah I have no idea I almost
signed up for stream yards yesterday but
I wanna I wanna do the videos in 4k
because I have my 4k camera over here
and Screen orange only goes up to 1080
I'm like I'd like to pay for this is
that's a free one or the say because
yeah I just use a free one that's what I
was going to do and then I was like well
I might pay for it but even like this
business plan only does 1080. like you
could be paying 500 a month and still
not get even 1260p it's insane that's a
bird or something
um but yeah yeah you have to pay for the
HD but I find if I do it in HD and I'm
inviting other people it lags that makes
sense I don't I don't worry about it but
you can definitely do it through YouTube
because I remember getting an email
telling me so but I mean if ever you're
free and you want someone to talk to
on there I've got 20 minutes to figure
out and then I'll be sending links here
all right man thank you so much
gentlemen um like I said go watch
through the video and bring up Stargate
thanks everybody thank you sorry I
forgot to mute
this is
y'all
foreign